hey youtubers is Charlie so this week on
agents of shield Cobie Smulders totally
came back as Maria Hill we saw the most
creative use of Lola that I've seen all
season and we found out who was behind
project Tahiti and I don't really know
if it was just because of Kobe's comedic
background and her presence in the
episode but it just felt like all the
jokes were just ten times funnier than
they normally are if you're finding me
for the first time I typically do Marvel
videos every Tuesday along with bonus
videos for the movies but since agents
of shield is almost over and you know
because today we found out who the new
Star Wars cast is those bonus videos are
gonna take the place of shield so be
sure to subscribe to get everything and
leave me suggestions for future bonus
videos so let's talk about what an
awesome shield agent Robin sparkles is
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet but here we go
top five moments number five ward is
Hitler Youth there big fight was a nice
explosion that I'd really been waiting
to happen for a long time I wasn't
really digging the mr. and mrs. Smith
diner scene so whenever they finally did
have it out on the bus I was really
happy usually when you put characters in
these confessional scenes is when the
truth starts to come out and we learned
a couple things first off Skye has
memorized part or most of the shield
handbook chapter one Red Skull was a
Nazi found at Hydra
ergo people who join Hydra are Nazis
funniest line in the episode and we
found out that Skye is probably not done
with Ward she said she's never gonna
give him what he wants what she meant by
that was obviously the drive and the
information on it and her you know cash
and prizes but because she gave the
information on the drive up whenever she
thought that Deathlok was gonna kill
Ward that kind of opens the door for
them to have a reconciliation or war to
have a Redemption arc number for Team
Coulson goes on vacation at a shitty
motel
I love scenes like this when it's just
the team chilling together out in public
it's like that scene in Iron Man 2 when
Tony Stark goes to get doughnuts and
Nick Fury and Black Widow share some
coffee with them maybe it's just seeing
superheroes do mundane everyday things
like using a vending machine or hanging
out by the pool but I think it's a lot
of fun I think it seems like this when
we get the real character development
when you start to fall in love with the
characters if you've ever seen any of
Joss Whedon's older shows like angel
Buffy or Firefly I always thought the
best scenes were whenever they were just
hanging out being friends I'm not sure
where the team is gonna be after the
finale and
Hill did tell Colson to release them or
you know to send them along to start but
I don't see that happening especially
since we know Nick Fury is still alive
and there's no way Nick Fury is gonna go
work for Tony Stark Fitz and Simmons
also said something that supports the
idea that the show is laying groundwork
for award redemption like when Fitz said
that he didn't believe that some people
are just evil I feel like what they're
sending up is like a Darth Vader
Return of the Jedi situation whereby you
know he ends up throwing Garrett down an
elevator shaft but let me know if you
agree number three cobie smulders is
back I totally love the Murray Hill
character so naturally whenever How I
Met Your Mother ended I crossed my
fingers that she'd guest star on shield
more often that's probably not gonna
happen mostly because her movie career
started to take off and she outranks
Coulson and really you know he should be
the most powerful main character
week-to-week
she's also moved back to New York to
live with her husband taran killam who's
on SNL full-time and shield shoots in
Los Angeles I do think we can expect her
to show up several times during season
two though I just loved the casual way
she named Drop Man Thing and Starks army
you know your brain naturally just races
to his armory you know as in Hall of
armors I'll talk about that more in a
future Avengers video but Joss Whedon is
kind of glossing over the end of Iron
Man 3 so he will have multiple armors
again but I'd really like to see from
her character more you know hopefully if
she's in the finale or in season two is
like a full-on fight scene she's
supposed to be one of the most fearsome
shield agents so why isn't she punching
people more like May does number two
Lola is the new escape plan one of the
best escapes all season I can only
imagine how much they spent on that
effect but all I could think whenever
they backed the car out and Skye flew up
in the air was that is why you wear a
seat belt
that's what seat belts are for Disney is
a family company so I feel like they
could run that scene by itself as a seat
belt safety PSA in schools and it'd be
pretty funny people would totally buy it
Coulson's reaction to Deathlok was
pretty hilarious - that's gonna be one
of my favorite chips all season you know
just as oh face and my number one
moment
Coulson is the man behind Tahiti did not
see that coming but Coulson is the man
behind Tahiti I saw a lot of you
commenting on Twitter that it was kind
of confusing so here's what was going on
Nick Fury commissioned project Tahiti as
a way of using alien probably Kree DNA
to develop the Jenner
drugs that they could use on mortally
wounded Avengers so say Tony Stark or
Black Widow almost dies or does die they
want a procedure that could bring them
back to life like the mirakuru on arrow
you know - the super-strength but just
like on arrow with the mirakuru the
alien blood just made everyone flip
their so the only way to fix that
was by rewriting people's memories so
Coulson thought that was so shady that
he basically tendered his resignation to
fury and told him to scrap the project
what probably ended up happening after
that was is that fury did scrap the
project but then Coulson died during
Avengers and it was still sitting there
in the bunker so fury used it on Coulson
and based on those notes knew that he
had to rewrite Coulson's memories so
that he wouldn't go crazy and die again
so fury wasn't trying to be a dick about
it
he only rewrote Coulson's memories so
that he would survive the procedure he
liked he wants his friend to stay alive
samuel l.jackson is guest starring on
the finales so I'm sure there's gonna be
a scene where the two of them just
resolve that issue but now it's your
turn let me know what your favorite
moment was you know was it the little
escape was it TD or was it Cobie
Smulders
you know I think we should call that
Chloe Bennet haircut the Lola so
whenever you go in to get your hair cut
and you tell him you want the Lola they
just stick you in front of a blow dryer
for like 15 minutes it's perfect for
Halloween costumes overall I give the
episode a B+ I love seeing Maria hill
again and the way they used her
character to bridge between Winter
Soldier and Avengers 2 was great
remember she said they're privatizing
world security that's actually gonna be
a big theme in Avengers age of Ultron
but we can talk about that more in a
future video I'm really glad that the
sky war drama is you know pretty much
over at least the drama part of it and
they can just start making fun of each
other using Hitler jokes that Coulson
Tahiti twist was a really nice wrinkle I
was actually surprised by that so I'm
always really impressed when a show can
surprise me
I hadn't really been invested in it too
much and I think a lot of us ended up
thinking that it was going to be another
Alexander Pierce Hydra reveal but I do
like the real explanation better I mean
really no one can hurt you as badly as
your friends can hurt you so he and fury
are gonna have some serious words all
that being said I'm really excited to
see where the end of the season leaves
the team I don't expect them to disband
but they might start taking funding from
Tony Stark I have a feeling he'll be
funding the Avengers by the time we get
to age of Ultron remember
privatizing world security so like I
said there's only two more agents of
shield episodes and as soon as shield
goes away this is gonna be like my
permanent day for Star Wars bonus videos
and Marvel movie videos be sure to
subscribe to get everything and leave me
suggestions for future topics but right
now you can click here to learn all
about the new Star Wars Episode 7 cast
they just announced and you can click
here to get last week's agents of shield
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you tomorrow
high fives
you